Gear for La.
So let's find the one that we disagree on.
I think you believe the official story of the JFK assassination.
Do you more or less?
Yeah,
more or less.
My belief,
and this is um,
this,
uh,
changes over time.
I think that Lee Harvey Oswald was in on it.
I think he was a part of it,
but I think there were multiple people that were in on it.
That's what I believe.
Do you think the multiple shooters?
Yes.
And the one of the reasons why I believe that is because of the formation of the
single bullet theory and the single bullet theory was formed because the fact
that they had to account for one bullet that hit the underpass ricocheted off
and put some man in the hospital.
Um,
and that before that they did not have an explanation for why all of these
bullets bullet holes,
all these wounds.
We're in all these different people's bodies.
The other reason why I'm inclined to believe there's a conspiracy was the fact
that they found that bullet on Connolly's Gurney when they brought him into the
hospital.
It's too convenient.
And the bullet itself is fairly pristine.
Now,
knowing as much as I know about bullets from personal experience of hunting,
you can't hit anything with a ball.
I pulled a lot of bullets out of animals.
When you shoot an animal and you hit bone,
those bullets,
they distort brutally.
I mean,
they don't look like that.
If they go through to people and hit all sorts of bone,
that's the bullet that came out of Connolly's body or Connolly's Gurney,
excuse me.
And that's the bullet that they're attributing to this,
a single bullet theory.
Uh,
if you look at the path of the bullet that goes through Connolly or goes through
Kennedy and then goes through Conley,
that to me is,
is not unbelievable.
It's not unbelievable that what it is that you've got to look at the other one,
but even that one,
but no,
no.
See what I'm saying?
Even that one is not unbelievable.
It is believable to me because I know that bullets do strange things when they
hit things.
Right.
But you,
you got to combine that with the fact that the bullet came out fairly pristine,
which meant it didn't actually go through a kind of a bouncy path light that it
went through a straight path.
This diagram is from a conspiracy theorist,
but essentially,
yes.
But the other diagrams that will show the actual path with him,
you know,
they've got them the butts,
they're on the same level and you know,
that uh,
Kennedy was actually sitting here was elevated.
Yes.
So,
um,
see if we can find one that has,
uh,
the actual seating arrangement or more accurate seating.
The,
well,
the one right there with the red line and the right hand side,
the one on the right hand side,
that's a more accurate,
um,
from above,
from above.
Yeah.
There's,
there's also the,
the fact that there was particles,
there was more metallic particles from the bullets,
more fragments from the bullet in Conley's body.
Then we're missing from the bullet.
I do not believe that was the bullet.
And I think that that is a very reasonable assumption.
Well,
you know what you should do?
You should get one of those guns.
Get the same bullets.
Okay.
Some ballistic dummies,
which some bones inside and start shooting.
They've already done that.
Yeah.
The Penn and teller did that.
Some people have it and they have found pretty close to what actually have
no,
they did within,
within the rounds.
No,
no.
Every bullet that hit bone got distorted.
That's just what happens.
The you and the shoot those bullets into water or you shoot those bullets until
like fluff or something like that,
that doesn't have a lot of impact to slow the bullet down.
Then you get a bullet that looks like that.
If you shoot a bullet into bone,
they distort wildly where the bone was,
the last thing that it hit,
but it doesn't matter.
It's still hitting bone.
But he stopped to that point.
Yeah.
But I mean,
didn't it hit bone in,
in Kennedy's body as well?
MMM.
[inaudible]
the odds of it hitting only soft tissue and it's going to go through his neck.
And he came out here that didn't clip one of his vertebrae or something like
that.
I don't think that's real.
I think also there's a difference between,
and this is fact from David Lifton's book best evidence,
which was a book by a,
an accountant to went over,
um,
the Warren Commission report and found all these factual inaccuracies and all
these,
um,
uh,
contradictions.
He found that there was a difference in the autopsy report at Bethesda,
Maryland,
the feds,
the naval hospital versus the,
uh,
the show.
What they had reported on the scene in Dallas,
the first doctors that got ahold of Kennedy's body in Dallas before they flew
him to Bethesda,
said that the hole in his neck was an entry wound.
When they got to Maryland,
they changed that to a tracheotomy hole.
They changed the,
the impact and they said that it was a,
they said that this was not an impact from a bullet,
that it was from something else.
Yeah.
Someone said they enlarge the hole.
Insert a trek cube.
Yeah.
Well,
I think,
well there was,
uh,
there was also a lot of pressure on these people to try to wrap this up nice and
tight and say that Lee Harvey Oswald was the shooter.
There was,
yeah,
yeah.
There's this big thing about the CIA,
the CIA inventing the,
uh,
the FBI,
the FBI will inventing the term conspiracy theory.
He was a CIA thing.
I think it was the CIA.
Yeah.
And this was a couple of years after the assassination.
They,
uh,
there was a memo that went out where they were concerned about all this
conspiracy theorists that were coming out and they used the term conspiracy
theories and,
and they,
they said they should try to,
uh,
basically debunk them and yeah.
Make the people who,
uh,
spread them around look like a conspiracy theorist.
Basically.
The theory is that the term conspiracy theory came from,
uh,
that particular memo,
but that memo,
they never actually encourage people to use the term.
Uh,
but yeah,
there was a huge concern from the CIA that they would be,
they would lose the trust of the public if people,
everybody started believing that it was a conspiracy theory.
At least that's what they said.
I mean,
maybe there is a conspiracy and maybe they are just trying to cover it up.
But
did you see the most recent dump of a information,
the Kennedy assassination that Jack Ruby had stated to people that before the
day of the Kennedy assassination,
keep an eye out today that's going to be fireworks.
I didn't say that.
Yeah,
those Jack Ruby who eventually wound up shooting Lee Harvey Oswald in front of
the police officer.
Yeah.
But you know,
something like that,
you know,
this is dead obviously.
Say you kept asking him what he actually meant,
uh,
and things like that take on a special significance after an event.
True.
Whereas he could be just talking about it like he was going to go visit his ex
wife or something or he was going to go to the bar or he was looking forward to
shouting at the parade or whatever.
Could have been nothing.
People say things and you know,
after something happens,
people go back and they look at everything that happened and then they say,
well,
that sounds like something significant.
Right?
Like with the Vegas shooting,
uh,
there was a woman walking around the crowd in the Vegas shooting,
saying,
you know,
you're all going to die.
This,
this is what some people said,
and this was like half an hour before the actual shooting itself.
So people take that event and then,
you know,
since a lot of people did die,
they think that this woman actually knew what was going to happen and she was
trying to warn people.
Right.
But you also get crates,
people wandering around saying things all the time,
especially in Vegas.
Yeah.
And the,
the problem with you're all going to die is that,
that's a common one.
Some guy was yelling that we took pictures of him when we were in Vegas long
before the shooting.
It was a few months ago.
Um,
we were,
uh,
standing,
no,
we were in a car.
He was standing on the corner and he had a stack of signs.
I put it up on my Instagram.
I know I did because there was many,
there was stacks of signs.
He had not just one sign.
He had like a long totem pole of signs with all these different things and I was
taking photos of it and the guy was yelling out,
everyone's going to die.
I mean he was yelling it out that you know God's wrath and all this,
you know crazy religious stuff.
That's a common thing for Christ's people to shout.
Yes.
What they do shout,
it's not like this woman was saying specifically someone's going to shoot
everyone at this concert,
get out of here.
This is a dangerous area.
If she was trying to well and then she would have been a bit more specific.
Yes,
very specific.
Right.
If she knew something.
Do you see that?
Do you find it?
No,
it's,
I know I put it up there cause we were mocking it.
Maybe I put it on my Instagram story and it went away.
I don't think so though.
I think it's,
it's there from,
I want to say,
I want to say it was at least six months ago,
but we were mocking this guy cause I like this guy.
I've got a lot of fucking signs.
Like one side's not enough.
I go was this is the guy,
this is the reason why Twitter only has 140 characters.
Motherfuckers like this.
I think I remember it was like July cause there's like 120 degrees out too,
wasn't it?
Yes,
it was very hot.
This goofy ass hole had this giant stack of signs.
Um,
so the,
the back to the Kennedy family,
what do you think happened?
Do you think the Lee Harvey Oswald probably acted alone?
I think it probably acted alone.
I think led the physics of what happened,
like is fairly consistent with,
uh,
the single shooter theory.
Now admittedly the
magic bullet is a bit strange,
but I don't think it's out of the rounds of possibilities.
Uh,
I do.
Yeah.
Because of the fact the metal particles,
there's more bullet fragments in Connolly's body.
Then we're missing from that almost pristine bullet.
And even though the fact that it hit Connolly at the very end,
if it went through all that flesh and it didn't hit any bone until it hit his
wrist,
then it would not have been compromised very much.
Ballistically it would still be going incredibly fast.
It still would have smashed into that bone.
It did enough to break his wrist and it would have distorted the bullet.
That's just what happens with bullets.
See,
unfortunately,
I didn't really follow JFK conspiracy very much.
And the reason I don't is that they're already like,
I think literally over a thousand books I've read,
I've read a few.
Um,
I got into case closed.
That was a Vincent Bugliosi.
His book is out who it was,
but I was like,
this guy has got an agenda.
It just didn't,
it.
There's,
there's many books that you could read,
uh,
about the Kennedy assassination.
And some of them favor the conspiracy and some of them favor the assassination.
I think they have a lot of them have merit on both sides.
One thing that drives me crazy when people say that you could never make that
shot.
That's fucking bullshit.
That's bullshit.
This is why I know it's bullshit because it was only like a couple hundred yards
and like a couple hundred yards shooting at something.
The size of a person's head is easy.
What about just even Chera trying to do the uh,
yeah,
three three shots against three shots off.
He didn't know what he's doing,
but I mean first of all you would,
if you are used to that rifle and you practice that wasn't,
someone said,
oh the scope was off.
I think that's bullshit too.
The reason why I think that's bullshit.
It's cause it's easy.
Knock a scope off.
You have to have a direct chain of evidence between the time we Harvey Oswald
had that scope shooting that rifle.
The moment he shot that rifle and then you have to hand it off to someone who
checks the scope right then because if you drop an rifle,
the scope goes off.
Just drop it.
I've done that before.
I dropped a rifle once when I was hunting in Wisconsin and my scope was off by
six inches at a hundred yards just dropping it.
So the idea that he could have never made that shot because the scope is off.
Scopes get adjusted.
That's what happens when you drop a scope.
They move.
That's,
that's a whole thing about ballistics.
You have to check them.
You go to the range,
you set up a a lead sled,
you lay the rifle down so it's perfectly stable.
You squeeze off a shot,
you use the binoculars,
you find out where the,
the shot hit on the target,
and then you adjust the scope.
They're adjustable.
So the idea that his scope was no good.
It's crazy.
The idea that that shot was too far to make insane.
It was only,
I think it was less than a hundred yards when they think you made the first
shot,
which is a chip shot,
that's a shot that you would make without even arrest.
Now he's making this shot resting on the window.
So He's perfectly steady.
The idea that that was impossible as crazy.
The idea that no one can do that in three shots.
That's been disproven.
Someone can do it.
Someone who's really good at reloading and loading can do it just because Jesse
Ventura couldn't do it,
but Jesse super conspiracy mind is like,
he goes all in with the conspiracy
vrs,
the motivated reasoning part of things at an NFS doing it just for his show or
because he really believes it.
I worked with the same people that did his show,
the same people that did his show.
The reason why I did Joe Rogan questions,
everything is they wanted me to take over Jesse show after it was done and I was
uninterested.
I was like,
I'm not going.
I'm not that guy.
I'm not like the,
I believe every conspiracy guy I go,
I think there's people,
I think people have a real weird vested interest in proving that things are a
conspiracy.
I'm interested in finding out what things really are like legitimately what they
really are.
Yeah,
and even if I'm wrong,
like I'm,
I have,
I'm not interested in reinforcing things.
I've already said,
if I find out that what I said was wrong,
I'm interested in repeating it.
I was wrong as many times as I can to get it out to as many people as I can.
Yeah,
I'm with you because I think it's important.
So this,
this JFK thing,
there's bullshit on both sides of it,
but the idea that this guy who went over to Russia,
married a Russian citizen,
came back here was,
I mean,
I mean he was absolutely involved in some shady,
weird shit with Cuba.
He's a fucking weird guy.
Like we have you,
Oswald was a weird guy.
The idea that he was completely innocent.
I'm not buying that either.
I,
yeah.
I don't buy the idea that it's proven that he acted entirely alone.
It's entirely possible that the other people who were like helping him or a
motivating you him or giving him the instructions even.
Yeah.
Uh,
the thing I,
I don't think it's really proven is the additional shooter theory.
It's not proven.
And there have been people that said they heard things from behind them.
The problem with that is chaos.
When you have gun shots,
first of all,
gun shots and an area like at Dealey Plaza,
the echos.
Yeah.
Echos ring out and people claim to see things and hear things and they even
believe themselves have you tell someone that you heard something in the bushes
and then you run away.
That person will say,
I heard something in the bushes,
and then other people were repeated.
It becomes the narrative and it just gets,
it's real hard.
Create Memories.